こんにちははじめ世津翁です今からハワイ
に旅行に行ってきます
ですがどうせ旅行に行くんだったら
ちょっと1個どうしても見てみたいものが
ありましてあの
besso 族にセカンドハウス私はじめ
佐藤ですねちょっとハワイにセカンド
ハウスが欲しいなと本気で思っておりまし
て
実はですねもうすでにああは上田さんの横
について日本とコロナとかで全然解決は
いけなくて結構実際見てみたいなと思っ
てるんですけど見れなくて今回ようやく
ちょっとハワイに行けるということで
ちょっとしてかなぁスコーンに殿八尾
オープンハウスさんというところである
程度を探してもらっているのでそれもう
ちょっと時間見つけていけたらいいなと
思って今回実は裏で肇社長のハワイのピエ
を
きます値段とか全然わかんないしある程度
味見しておりますけれどももう行ったほう
があるかどうかでまして決めようかと思っ
てるすっぽん実はめっちゃ楽しみなハワイ
の物件探し
スタートです飛行機いきますピュア
軽い軽い
rar 入っていました
me
艶美な入る
ついてきてくれてありがとういやこさせて
くれてありがとうご案内してくださる方も
いらっしゃるということでよろしく
ね国会4筋トレさせていただけるという
ことです結構撮影が続けられている中で
ちょっと取らせてくださっと焼くのが好き
1軒目ということでね
wh20例
行くぞ
あ待って待って待って are you
tube マッサージ感ですよ白い泥
えっこんな多くなはずでやっぱり
多く破産だけね
これがもしてかうってなったら今住んでる
方がなく受けてくださいねねえええリンク
元こんな感じになっておりますいやーこっ
から
ています
ゆきみて毛布いっ
やばいやばいですえお
1めっちゃ綺麗
後戻りましょうか触れるこの道
sd 切れ
デニーズの広さはマジで拾えてせる良いと
は推定なこずトレーニングされてるから
なってフィットでしているような空間をお
湯であるしねパワー何人座れるんですか
ううううううっ
ウールは一番似合う
旧式店じゃないん
だりすぎでしょこれはすごいよいる空間
広い区
でこんな駄文
ご飯食べる場所かすごいよ
まずして5位女
決定こっちへ開いて言って大タイピング
そんな感じですね混ぜオープンの空間広い
ついて k 4ペア食べていきましょうか
やばいんじゃないん
めちゃめちゃいいねぇ
これはすごいねほんとに収まりの良さを
満喫できるよいいですねこれいやいや
いやいや
2000ややばいよ俺オリバーおうちも
そうだってくればハワイっていう空間が
凄い魅力的でベランダでですぐこういう月
に入ってるのは本当に年から一つポイント
になりそうです
1球目からそんな飛ばせ大丈夫俺も結構
なびかないよむっても変わって言ったから
だよこれを返した別によるすけどねそうで
ちっち見ていきましょうか
数字さん
22 the 海外みたいなご飯作ったら
すぐ出てくるって言う唯一持つんあります
ね広いでポンと空撮多いわ
いいなぁ
みんなでねなんか作って食べてますね
同じ抑えてクラス募集中ですねなるほど
もう一にありました文句ギア c 4つか
ここ
あああああてくれよ
こりゃゴージャスだよ案内ゴージャスて
言葉全然で使うやっぱこれはゴージャスで
ある
いい
枕数真っ暗橋場うっ見て僕なんだここでも
あるがすごいにカシャるってことでし
ベランダから智くんでもちょっと頭に
ありますか白いなぁ
ここがバスルームですねうわぁガラスばり
のステーキナースできない
白くて綺麗ですねきれいられた癖みたいは
2つあるので
お二人レッスンでも汗なんかええええ
はい一緒にできたらいいね生じていく急い
でいかなく胎のうのではなかったもう人や
これやべーわ
レス外相
ませんパッドを買ったせる多数やる人には
だけじゃないぞ
8倍中
ルー足がとベッドルームなん
うーんやべー
は子離れほんと
やばいよどーすかそこで編集
いや
捗るね打つ疲れたら後ろ向いたりしたら
もう罹病作ったそしてシャワールームもう
1回よくタップ全然広いすごくもちゃんと
触れる
パルスパースルームもついている見せたい
けどね第1 d 偶然ついていると思う
そしてこちらにもう1部屋こちらのベッド
ルームですね
いやーすごいよすごいよいやいやいやー
そのてから本当にマジで本当に考えるから
買おうか色々素材取ると夢みさせて
いただきますありがとうございました
すごいですねー
ですよねちっ例はこれ問題からと母にきた
なーっていう
そうですねぇ
オヘア本当に多いです
はいそうで節水ベッドルーム3バースデー
もう全然的になる
[音楽]
もうすごいを見ますです
すぐするんですよはいここにはいお願いし
ます降ったらちょっと村でお値段みたいな
部分と普陀山2なんでしょそうですねえ
こちらは2.8ミリオンで
非常に出しておりますぼーっと一緒に
かかり坂もキター8
すっ
2.8秒ですよね
ミリオンってなんだっけ
えっ2億8000万んそうですねはい
寒い誠さんくらいそうですねはいそうです
ね
あのゆるかなぁ
けどそれぐらいですねもうコップ2
year
ありゃああすごいなぁありがとうござい
ますちょっと襲っ極右政党であるんです
けどもまだ3文献入れるさあではい日目
ですけど次情緒に賢明です
いけないですねはいジョンウンならもう
アナというコンドミニアムの1505して
です
なんかさっき見たんですけど7回にプール
が2旅公演があったり二木ゴルフ場が
あったかいにマメにティっていいですか
はいすごいですねっ
もうそっと
にょみたいな
て会で音がポイントとしては外説明と思っ
てちょっとお部屋のところかなりになって
おりますね4はいどうぞいきましょう
う
ああああああああ meここが玄関入って
しするちがうっていうなんかアメリカっ
ぽいんや十分な広さこんなやったらもう
そして
が出てくるからウェディング何か思うん
ですけどもう
ein
こんなフレーム見たことないよすっげー
なーすげーちょっと今他の方が
いらっしゃって取れないですけどこの下に
もでっかいプールがあります今でカップル
が2人で使ってる hulu
いいねぇいいねぇ2力っていうのが
めっちゃ来たーー
例えば正直じゃあねやってきてざまあって
感じなんですけど一つできるここがマギー
ぐですねスゴイねでもめちゃめちゃ切れ
ああこっちですね室ですねはい室です
わー
いいなぁ
しっかりこちらも大きな基づいている景色
が見えますああここしか品質穴があると
うん
まあ通すかボスからどうぞ
あーカウンターわーからでしたそれで
を
あと5時間今ここにしよう本部がばする
なんかハワイって基本的にがーさが入って
この透明何かいいなぁ
全米はもうわーかっちがー
なるベッドルーム
八景こっちが一さんがやったことね違うれ
ないやですあっちが息子の部屋を放った
ボスエリート2つ入っている中晩生はこん
だけあればいや十分よ
来るところじゃないよー結構さっきの部屋
と比べて高カッターでなっているほどの
全然広いする
んねぇドルーを2つあっています
選べるのちゃんとアメニティの存在が俺な
んだけどで階あんまりをリストてないん
ですけど戦後インドアで応じてていタイプ
おうちの中にブルーバードが本当に
ちょっと無料もなります
お姉さん気になる
お値段なんとかこちら側で中ポイント56
で集中全敗のでがー
2.5に2いい手首用
さっきよりメジャー前に汗はいそう
いやちょっとはさっきの大きさをとるか
こっちでもずっとさをとるかっていう
パティスリーはーいスター
nude コンドミニアムというか
マンションあのー見てきたんですけど
今日は一軒家といいますかもうこの
バウワーてがよ
1塩だれうますっ
これで打っ
こっちもですかえっ
やばいってこれってこというかこれ持って
ほしいですよねうん
一瞬ってことを待って広いなあ
それが3区画ぐらいやってそのこっちと
思ってたら全部見たいですこれ規模すごい
ぞ今回色ヤシの木オレンジぬ
販売4倍あるのはっさく入ってみますか
楽しみだねこの家すごいねー大崎も突然や
ちょっと値段とうちになるんですけどそれ
最後に聞いていきたいとおもいます
いろいろてくれん
なぜ結構自然あふれる感じがあるん
さあハワイってたんですけども昨日とそこ
方向的世界の別荘の児童はなんか結構
海が使いというかショッピングモールと
もう使えないかそう言っていけな感じでし
たけど僕はもう年間どっしり構える感じの
街で持ってる人の家みたいな感じがあり
ますという意味でさっそく入っていき
ましょういきますお願いします今回 ok
ん
[音楽]
ランやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
そんなて海へ k 月に見せたい逆にこれ
は俺も半身に入っちゃってるからそれも
入っているその無いって言うやばいやばい
を張ってるヤバい八重歯
じゃあちょっとご覧くださいどうぞ
いやーいいです
ヤバイですってやねぇ
やべえよこれ
んじゃパワー
ブーバーこれ
すごいねほんとに何か大丈夫かこれ値段高
機能なとちょっと左ことにならないような
規模感なんだけどもうちょっと浮かれて
言ってるでしょ
ブービーてきた消費
あっ
夏ちょっと景色がすぎて衝撃的で外か
ございましたが机とかもすごいねぇなんか
おしゃれていきます
なになに最後の晩餐 dj ジャン違い
ない待って待って待って待って何これ
サミットをこれこれ enjoy んだよ
ねぇー
を持つ方
4日
うん方のクラブませ
んのがあってano まあで一つ床を止め
ていきましょう
yeah あウエアを待ってみたいとなる
グラデーションと指を発見しました
真っ黒毛包ようしっかり金だからそう言う
というかの親父
ここだから一箇所ちっちゃい子においてに
なったら太田の喫煙所になります
ありがとうございます
こっちも言ってるんです
そしてこっちもずっといけるんですよ
の端バージョンこっち行くぞ一回って言い
ますか
強い強い山クロエ
あなたのためだけに触るんですかあなたを
ためだけにそれはと収納なんだろうね線
ですよねっ
めっちゃかわいいニャー
入るねー
大
詰まったじゃああまりにも大きすぎて管理
できないという例だと思う機械工具
つながっている
9校1回旦那になると生き物様みたいな
めこ妖怪だとりあえず1回ゼミをお願いし
ますはインタビュー集のですから
ターゲットに置きますいやー
[音楽]
をまっすぐというに
味
あサーバーはあるし
金色のフレームで
か損ですね社員と山登頂記
なんかする際縁もこだわってるイメージ
あるねえ
すごいなぁ
[音楽]
ちょっとなってくれ
文字全て見てましたちょっとあの徴兵制だ
から多すぎてくるんじゃないい祖母集合
ですかなぁこれぞはぁにレイジが限られて
いる牛削れてよ
ブーバー
しかーしロスよ4
収納がしっかりジョビすごいん
このすごいものがいいですよこれは何だ
アン収納な処分がもう
靴と貼ろうとして没なこっ
ゆうきん
何によっ中
マジで中発でこれやわー
big ron
だってさぶっここでいや遺産
新居にんただで済むん
寝るをできるキングサイズのベットを言わ
れますよこれぞ
壁がどうかねうんあった
ふーん2年家を作るアルフは結構落ち着い
た空間という
いやー
こうやっているはけど景色
これだねぇ
よくないねぇ
これやばいんだよくないよこれ一方変え
だけだっつん
スピーカーるーるー
きってことはまさかさあかあっ
この白た好きじゃないかみたいな感じで
ちゃいますよ
ウールは年間大容量でみんなで見る
ちょっと待って1回かなと思ってないです
二回もある
どうする
日本町で終わらんですよお久しぶり4作
だけでもすごいのは70分のアプリが全敗
こんなんやでも少しでフレッツがー
ません
プール
鯖はけどクソトメに方法
もう長官ないですね気になるとみられる
いやけど結構市街から離れてるからそこで
ちょっと言いやすかったっていうものの
規模が凄すぎる
色多分単価常温奥パラダイス買って応援
[音楽]
明治がすれば
まいんワインセラーがでこいつかっこいい
ねらもかっこいい萌えも雨になってから
じゃねぇん
まあ8つにもあるは言えばそうか
これ終わらんぞ yeah で終わりは来
やばいですねサクサク気持ちましたよと
なって
保育はロッカーがあり8月使えるやつです
かねまっなトリガーああいうように考えて
くれるならばになるかだ
空気ままやここに来る前ですって
ハワイに友達君だけですね笑
みなさんよろしくねじゃあ心は2回目で
いきましょうか2階です
[音楽]
あの葉の部分だ1階の広い今の上に
ここで見れるんです
うーんまん
もう全部収納なんなこりゃすごい必要
やばいする
横井2マッチですねこれはもうアイ
キャント understand ろーっ
だいぶ使い切るカットして実施ずアメリ
カっ
うわぁこれは
中身がなかったことなかったダンスの
レッスン統一
まずそういう部屋無から有
me
何頭もこの上
ここも部屋にできる4棟ございますそう
ディスるねうん
3つみたいなだけます
なぁで何食べるか論文どこだとらえるも
ナンパメートルも怒りませんさぁさぁ
ここが
うなはすごい
どうする買っちゃうこれまずそれはで出し
たいコメントとかじゃなくてもんと見て
食べるでしょ凄いの一言に尽きるんですよ
神様
わぁ
ま食べてるわけだした残土へと今変わるし
あった交代で見ている
装置れるなど収納スペース& d センタ
軍ができたりとか交通のですねここでも
メインで打ってがマスターズをいただか
なかっ連れて皆
きましたこれええええ
じゃあこれが端一さんの部屋頭ですね
にこえー
[音楽]
ブーバーけどちょっとすごいぬ風貌力と
言いますか昨日にょ県と思った個性が強い
というか本当にポニーすんだーらーん水
瀬谷
オッケーって感じますブログでございまし
た
10元にというちょっと気になるお値段
聞いてみたいと思います
おはような
9本牌譜ミュー家裡に終えさあ
20位
エロ淫乱
ファイフミュリアぬぬんらいんみーにゃん
ぱいファンズダウザーね
9ミリ音が入っ
line ミギョン日本円で今13
今の女だったうん
うわぁ
おりますね大
まだ見ない方になるじゃないみたいですね
ここどうぞ
ミーティ版バスケットボーラーにもう
なんかいい感じのうんそれどこまでか合う
でもわかんないですとりあえず多分ほぼ
全部いいですねっ
あれもいえる誰のためにですあれモレノ
それは何んそれは
ガーレンですねこれ持って行って
るってこと時はこの木も私のマジすか
これはですか別の方の打つ
[音楽]
えっ
今メンテナスの方のお家ですもうて男性の
方のお家オレンジで大地くんの家みたいな
感じですよあのを奪え作るの家が近くやる
みたいな感覚ね
[音楽]
には hiro さんこいん
あって
[音楽]
湖
何がに振舞ってるんだこれ
ルールだプールだこれ
やばこれプルって判例大丈夫です
そうなと思う
これは燃え立つ尽くしちゃっぷ行ってく
るー
[音楽]
puniドレーパー了承すごいな全部には
売ってくれ
[音楽]
距離口笛吹いてるここが入り月っぽいです
ね
なんかちょっとガラッとイメージが変わっ
てちょっと何かね but you 君
マジあったりうっいきましょうかめざ
シートビビらないようにするわするして
いただきます
してしまう
運んだなぁ
イヤホン蔵です
全日本の0分
nars 美術界に思います頑張って
これももうなんかプレスルームとが中が陰
でもないかもねっなーんでなるほどね
さっき最初に頭にはなかったら meets
プールも見えると
手にしましたが降る月
きましたね
そしてこそで流れ
を
うわ動くぞえん
[音楽]
がち
0寸
みんなで見るんですよ
[音楽]
からもこれ
いやだよねー
スズヤでこの広さ
やばいねかなり白くなってますこの
スペースを切っちゃいました何かやって
奥行き動作まあ切っちゃう特に広いのは
もうわかるんですけど
岡行き食材とかおっん
なるほどねえぞ打ったところホッと
フィリア者とストーリーも違うとリア
じゃあまあ2部物語いうとではへの子です
けど保存できるまあここは外につながって
いると感じも十分の広さかっございます
やばいよパッと見た瞬間にはが広くて
サーフィン
ヌー殺菌や夏すごいか習って招致思ってた
んだけどここのすごいコインランドリー
じゃねぇ
装い台でそんなにうわーんだからされたん
ですしゃべれん
押され+9もうショルダー
[音楽]
まだ始めたのじゃないですよ
買ってから買ってくださいいやー時
メンバーのうちらすごい魅力っていうね
かわいい
一望できましたしプールも付いてるに広い
お庭
いやにバイオキロってことさ
いやーこれは完璧だねには広いのほど見
るっ
にょ家がチャンジュニョ
ン
ちょっとすっぱいようにしたミクだよ
[音楽]
5巻内容とめいいですよね右で集
服の種の花
旨そう巨大からのです
一人は運ありえないですねタブーまず住ん
でカッター
買ったら末ですます
近く待って言ってちゃんと奥さんだけでも
値段建つ家買ってくるって言っ
てっくじゃこれ
えっ
恋はこんなネクタイとないでしょうね入っ
てそうなった所もじゃあもういいやつもへ
大学足しておりぱする
すっごいズレさ
これ
私を
yeah
なーんまず違うん
いるなにこのべし4 a
変化すごい兄挑んだけど家と比べ余裕だっ
て言ってるのんで免除を過ごしていた
らしい
だって今のところ13億の家とサンオクの
マンションを2つ見てるだけですかここが
わかるんですけどもいます
[音楽]
これでそう
万寿台た入手値段が患者のか
まとりあえず1回はだいたいこんな形です
全然な文物が見えていないたんですけども
大きなお部屋はぬんだという感じでも本当
に感覚としては空間に余裕を持たせて
くれるなんかブーツっ
すぐによくなるこれだけ見たどこに言うと
俺美術が壮大でいきますか
インターのスペースもすごいよこれを24
客した登れ縁ですねおりっ子はれないけど
こういうさあ点と高いもすごい中
[音楽]
誘導文せ発言はすごく大事に思っている
広すぎますね
いいはぁっ
袋
どうするどうする
[音楽]
ブーバー
漆器白い色さんっ
先生じゃなかったああなるんねそれを
それぞれ県政をやるんです
霧寝れるけども工夫するねすごい
遊んでここからもう
[音楽]
とおっしゃいますこれすごい
すごい歩道高さまで観たひとつって美術館
の見学きた方と思って家ですよこれ
キッズ量のサイズじゃねーよな親バカ親
バカ俺の近所のおもちゃ屋さん以上に
でかいとこな部屋子供の時からこんな所
告げたらませんですよ
部屋はんよこいつは土佐2世降ってきて
いるファンキーのお客が始まっちょっと
ずつここができたんだけどここがせ始める
と同旅客 e 2
そしてを配るんだからまだあるまだ混ぜよ
ません
ここで上から物音動画撮れそうですね
ばっっまだまだあるんですよ
[音楽]
入ってるでベレー
ん広いよ
これやばいっすこういう日[ __ ]日々て
ますよね
[音楽]
に向かいが起こっつが私
言えばすることで作られた
me言葉がでもこれは映像をそこに入れ
ますか
結構9分
[音楽]
ハマチ
ファッキンミューエないハイターせぬ us
だーです
t 魅了
客さん2
万ドルということは
水サンオクは超えている
受注中86
そんな値段でしょうね日本もすごい時室内
をすごいから週初
なるほど
予定
セイリングタイプたーーー
そんなすぐ決めることでこれだけ入った
わけで今回ですねあのオープンハートさん
のおかげで本当にいろんなセミナー物件を
見ることができましたありがとうござい
ましただから急遽だったから本当に柔軟に
対応してくださってスムーズいろんなプッ
キ見ると思わなかったほんとすごい物件だ
けど
や慣例がせてくださいまだいろいろ紹介し
ていただいたりとかいろんな見てちょっと
度量
僕の世界のファッションショーが考えさせ
ていただきたいと思いますので多く
ハンサムだよろしくお願いますあとに余裕
があるユーチューバー
ウィンフリーさんの皆さんもぜひご検討
ください
[音楽]
ブーバーし